a group of pro-democracy activists in
hong kong have been sentenced for taking
part in
anti-government protests in 2019 veteran
campaigner martin lee
who helped launch the city's largest
opposition party in the 1990s was given
a suspended sentence
of 11 months but media tycoon jimmy lai
received a 12-month jail term the 2019
protests were spurred
by beijing's tightening of freedoms in
hong kong
we can go live now to adrian brown he
joins us from hong kong outside the
courthouse
you were there for those hearings adrian
what more can you tell us
well yes jimmy lye has received as you
say a 12-month sentence that sentence
will now begin on friday
significantly additionally on friday two
new charges
were laid against jimmy lie including
another one
under the draconian national security
law that means that jimmy lye
is now facing three charges under the
national security law
in addition to another charge and
remember
there's been a campaign in mainland
china
for jimmy lai to stand trial there so
the fact he's now facing three charges
under the national security legislation
may make it easier
for that possibly to happen now jimmy
lie
as you say has received a 12-month
sentence the judge took into
account various mitigating factors the
fact that jimmy ly's health
is not good the fact he had no previous
convictions
but she also said that a deterrent
sentence was necessary she said the
activists knew full well that they were
defying the police
by taking part in that unauthorized
protest on august the 18th 2019
this was a protest that drew according
to the organizers
1.7 million people and that was a time
when emotions really were very high in
hong kong
and the magistrate argued that you know
it was possible that demonstration
which was peaceful could well have
become violent
martin lee as you mentioned the father
of democracy here in hong kong who
helped to co-author the basic law hong
kong's mini-constitution
received an 11-month sentence that's
been suspended for
two years a mitigating factor in his
case
is the fact that he is 82 years old so
we have
four people who have received suspended
sentences
and five others who have been jailed for
terms between
eight months and 18 months
thank you very much indeed adrian brown
there reporting live
from hong kong